santiago básicamente lo que usted acaba
de decir ya que la información ha salido
por términos de investigación
independiente que berlín pidió a sus
socios europeos ya que recordemos
en general
hicieron unos análisis y no encontraron
ninguna sustancia tóxica en el organismo
del opositor de 44 años por lo mismo lo
único que sabemos de estos informes es
que coinciden con el que hizo el
hospital militar en berlín el pasado 3
de septiembre de nabai y fue envenenado
con un agente en neurotóxico del tipo no
dijo que estos agentes como sabes atacan
el sistema nervioso de la persona que
pierde poco a poco el control de sus
músculos y termina muriendo ya sea por
una
dejar una parada cardiaca o por nada
berlín a ha reconocido que el uso de
este tipo
y pedir una investigación a la
organización internacional en contra del
uso de las armas químicas por su parte
mockus sigue negando esta versión como
decíamos ellos niegan haber encontrado
una sustancia tóxica en el cuerpo del
opositor quieren entrevistarlo y quieren
conocer toda la investigación que ha
llevado a alemania al respecto erika
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de parís